in the ancient book is written that a
warrior will draw a burning sword from
the fire and that sword shall be
Lightbringer
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie you guys have
been asking me all kinds of questions
about barracks flaming sword azor Ahai
and light bringer as the TV show treats
it versus the books so I'm just going to
explain what's going on
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far and there is a
new round of the giveaway I'll explain
at the end of the video but that scene
from Melisandre is actually a book scene
from Davos is chapter and a Storm of
Swords where you learn about the red God
through Melisandre is character she says
that prophecy in the book it says there
will come a day after the long summer
when the stars bleed and the cold breath
of darkness falls heavy on the world in
this dread hour a warrior shall draw
from the fire a burning sword in that
sword shall be Lightbringer the red
sword of Heroes and he who clasts it
shall be azor Ahai come again in the
darkness shall flee before him so very
literally you're seeing a version of
that scene play out here with beric
Dondarrion lighting a sword on fire as
they're getting ready to battle the
night king because it looks like this
scene is attached to this scene here
with him standing on the rock you can
even see the sword flaming in the
background here with the Hound standing
next to them facing the other direction
like all crap but a lot of people are
like wait a minute is it Jon Snow
supposed to be the prince who was
promised a Zora hi what's the difference
between all these things what about
light bringer what are the mechanics of
that how do you set the sword on fire
what kind of crazy magic is he invoking
from the red God when he does that
between Stannis and Barrack we've seen
at least three flaming swords on the TV
show we've seen Barry do it twice
because I just included that clip and in
the longer version of that early clip I
included with Melisandre talking about
light bringer Stannis walks up to one of
the idols of the Seven and Yanks a
flaming sword out of it and then puts it
in the snow we all know that Melisandre
doesn't have a great track record with
accuracy she's interpreting prophesies
from the past there's a great long
history of the idea of azor Ahai that
goes all the way to the far east the
ancient history there's always the story
of some big apocalypse happening in a
mythical figure coming along the people
of all the different cultures of the
world within Game of Thrones
have different names for that person in
a Zora hi is just one of those names we
even saw a preview image of Gilly and
Samwell in the Citadel the page that
she's reading is actually a page talking
about the history of azor Ahai and all
the different cultures the TV show does
a really good job of setting up big
concepts then paying them off like it
prepares you for a big magical twist
beric Dondarrion is what I'm going to
call the explainer character he's called
the lightning Lord because of his sigil
looks like a bolt of lightning but the
way the TV show has changed his
character is it's turned him into an
explainer for really big crazy concepts
so you listen to Melisandre talk about
how he got resurrected by the red God
six times that was all the way back in
season three you cut to the beginning of
season six Jon Snow is dead and even if
you ignore all the narrative cues that
tell you that he's a main character and
is going to be much more important in
the future you still wonder what's going
to happen to him but you listen to
things like this Melisandre believes so
strongly in the power of the red god
that Jon Snow was the prince who was
promised even though she just got done
believing that Stannis was that person
she has her crisis of faith but then
tries again and brings him back so
suddenly he realized why they spent so
much time in that barrack moment with
Melisandre and Thoros so I'll say right
off the bat I do not think that Barrack
is azor Ahai but he is wielding a
version of Lightbringer I think those
terms are just ways of talking about
really important figures it's meant to
be a generalization the prophecy of the
prince who is promised is written in
high Valyrian is gender-neutral
Daenerys is also a princess who was
promised to her song is also a song of
ice and fire just like Jon Snow is
literally the child of Ice and Fire
Lyanna stark in Rhaegar Targaryen so
there is no one magical Ozora high
character but in the way the show
explains things it shows you how barrack
lights his sword on fire
so one it involves a blessing from the
red God there's actually a magical
sacrificial component to it like he
gives up his own blood there is power
and blood Melisandre is obsessed with
Jon Snow's blood in the more kingly your
blood the more powerful it is
so if Derek is able to light his sword
on fire sort of infusing it with the
power of the red God strengthening it
then think about what Jon Snow would be
able to do with his blood there's some
special reasons why I think that barrack
in the Brotherhood were sent north of
the wall with Jon Snow on this special
mission here but there's also more
practical reasons that they put it in
the
trailer because you see it you're like
oh my god is that a Zora high flame
ensued what's going on no that's not
what they want you to take away from
that one I think the narrative reason
for Barrett going north of the wall is
to give John Snow and explain or give us
in the audience the explainer for what's
going to be happening next season the
crazy powers that Jon Snow will invoke
when he's fighting the White Walkers in
the second big reason is that it just
looks really badass so that anybody
walking by on the street who didn't know
anything about Game of Thrones saw
somebody light a sword on fire will get
really interested they really want to
make fans happy they want to make a good
show but they want as many people to
watch these the last two seasons as
possible so they're going to show you
every trick they have in the bag and a
flaming sword is a pretty big trick but
the more important reason the narrative
reason is that in the books there's a
Lady Stoneheart plot that Barrack is a
part of where he literally gives his
last life to her it's his seventh time
to be brought back and he sort of passes
his life force into Lady Stoneheart
resurrecting her in sending her on her
mission of vengeance now the TV show has
cut that character out so I think the
narrative reason for Barrett going north
of the wall is one to give Jon Snow more
of a mystical education that he didn't
get from Melisandre he sent her away so
there's still a lot of things that he
doesn't understand about the red God
about the power that brought him back so
he's going to see that play out through
Thoreau's in Barracks character who are
total believers but too he's also the
backup resurrection for Jon Snow he
could literally pass his lifeforce to
Jon if he falls when they're fighting
all these White Walkers Barrack isn't
necessarily at the top of my death
predictions list but because of the way
his character went down in the books I
feel like he's ready to throw himself on
that sword when they're in this moment
here and it just feels like a bit of a
hat tip for them using him for a Big Jon
Snow twist and setting up even more
spectacular looking things more flaming
swords next season so hopefully that
explains the mechanics of Lightbringer
literally just takes a blessing from the
red God in some of your own blood the
more powerful your blood the more
spectacular the effect into the Lady
Stoneheart breath of life twist just
passing life from one person to another
getting the most important people where
they need to be so if they fall in
battle you can bring them back but
a very very special thing which is why I
think the Thoreau's and Barrack are both
standing there so anybody that is
standing there fighting those white
walkers is definitely going to be a
believer if they weren't already I feel
like that's the whole point of this they
want to bring back proof that there's
this threat of the army of the Dead so
that people like Cersei who absolutely
do not give a crap about any of it will
crap their pants and they can start to
put their differences aside before
season 8 but let me know in the comments
what do you guys think is going on with
Barrack this season do you think that
he's going to be one of the people to
die when they go north of the wall and
what's going to happen next is because
there's a holiday weekend coming up I'm
expecting some special Game of Thrones
stuff to happen but leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below
congratulations to Chris you're the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
Game of Thrones
while you wait for everything you can
click here for my trailer video and you
can click here for all my other season 7
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight